so
out of the moment of love out of the
moments of loss
can we uh talk about your journey of
finding i think an incredible idea an
incredible company
and incredible system in replica
how did that come to be so yeah so i was
a journalist
and then i went to business school for a
couple years to
um just see if i can maybe switch gears
and do something else with 23.
and then i came back and started working
for a businessman in russia who
built the first 4g network um in
our country and was very visionary
and asked me whether i want to do fun
stuff together
and we worked on a bank the idea was to
build a
bank on top of a telco so that was 2011
or 12.
and a lot of telecommunication company
mobile network operators didn't really
know
what to do next in terms of you know new
products new revenue
and this big idea was that you know um
you put
a bank on top and then all work works
out
basically your prepaid account becomes
your bank account and um
you can use it as as your bank uh so
you know a third of a country wakes up
as your bank client
um but we couldn't quite figure out what
would be the main interface to interact
with the bank
the problem was that most people didn't
have smart smartphones back in the time
in russia the penetration of smartphones
was low um
people didn't use mobile banking or
online banking on their computers
so we figured out that sms would be the
best way
because that would work on feature
phones uh wow but that required some
chatbot technology
which i didn't know anything about um
obviously so i started looking into it
and
saw that there's nothing really well
there wasn't just nothing that was
the idea is through sms be able to
interact with your bank account
yeah and then we thought well cool since
you're talking to a bank account why
can't this
can't we use more of you know some
behavioral ideas and
why can't this uh banking chatbot be
nice to you
and really talk to you sort as a friend
this way you develop more connection to
it
retention is higher people don't turn
and so i went to very depressing
russian cities to test it out i went to
i remember three different towns with uh
to interview potential users so people
use it for a little bit
cool and i want to talk to them um
very poor towns mostly towns that were
um
you know sort of factories uh mono
towns they were building something and
then the factory went away and it was
just a bunch of
very poor people um and then we went to
a couple that weren't
as dramatic but still the one i remember
really fondly was this woman that worked
at a glass factory and she talked to
chatbot
um and she was talking about it
and started crying during the interview
because she said no one really cares for
me that much
and so to be clear that was the
my only endeavor in programming that
chat boss it was
really simple it was literally just a
few
if this then that rules and um
it was incredibly simplistic and still
that made her
and that really made her emotional she
said you know i have my mom and my
um my husband and i don't have any more
really in my life
and it was very sad but at the same time
i felt and we had more interviews
uh in a similar vein and what i thought
in a moment was like well
uh it's not that the technology is ready
because
definitely 2012 technology was not ready
for
for that but um humans already
unfortunately
so this project would not be about like
tech capabilities would be more about
human vulnerabilities but um there's
something so
so powerful around about conversational
um ai that i saw then that i thought
was definitely worth putting in a lot of
effort into
so in the end of day we sold the banking
project um
but my then boss was also my mentor and
really really close friend um told me
hey i think there's something in it
and you should just go work on it i was
like well what product
i don't know what i'm building he's like
you'll figure it out
and um you know looking back at this it
was a horrible idea to work on something
without
knowing what it was which is maybe the
reason why it took us
so long but we just decided to work on
the conversational tech to see what it
you know
there were no chat bot
um constructors or programs or anything
that would allow you to actually build
one
at the time uh that was the era of by
the way google glass which is why
you know some of the investors exceeded
investors we talked with were like
oh you should totally build it for
google glass if not we're not
i don't think that's interesting did you
bite on that
idea no okay because i wanted to be
to do text first because i'm a
journalist so
i was um fascinated by just texting
so you thought so the emotional um that
interaction that the the woman had
like so do you think you could feel
emotion from just text
yeah i saw something in just this pure
texting and also thought that
we should first start start building for
people who really need it versus people
have google glass
uh if you know what i mean and i felt
like the early adopters of google glass
might not be overlapping with people who
are really lonely and might need some
you know someone to talk to
um but then we really just focus on the
tech itself we just thought what if we
just
you know we didn't have a product idea
in the moment and we thought what if we
just look into
building the best conversational
constructor so to say
use the best tech available at the time
and that was before the first paper
about deep learning applied to dialogues
which happened in 2015
in august 2015 uh which google
published did you follow the work
of lobner prize and like all the
sort of non-machine learning
chat bots yeah what really struck me was
that you know
there was a lot of talk about machine
learning and deep learning like big data
was a really big thing
everyone was saying you know the
business well big data yeah 2012's the
biggest
kaggle competitions were you know
important but that was really the kind
of uphill people started talking about
machine learning a lot
um but it was only about images or
something else
and it was never about conversation as
soon as i looked into the conversational
attack it was all about
something really weird and very outdated
and very marginal and felt very hobbyist
it was all about laura berner price
which was one by a guy who built
a chat ball to talk like a ukrainian
teenager it was just a gimmick
and somehow people picked up those
gimmicks and then you know
the most famous chat bot at the time was
eliza from
1980s which was really bizarre or a
smarter child on
aim the funny thing is it felt at the
time not to be that popular and it still
doesn't seem to be that popular
like people talk about the touring test
people like talking about it
philosophically journalists like writing
about it
but it's a technical problem like people
don't seem to really want to
solve the open dialogue
like they they're not obsessed with it
even folks like
of in you know in boston the alexa team
even they're not as obsessed with it
as i thought they might be why not what
do you think
so you know what you felt like you felt
with that woman
when she felt something by reading the
text
i feel the same thing there's something
here what you felt
i feel like alexa folks
and just the machine learning world
doesn't feel that that there's something
here
because they see as a technical problem
it's not that interesting
for some reason it's could be argued
that maybe as
a purely sort of natural language
processing problem
it's not the right problem to focus on
because there's too much subjectivity
that that thing that the woman felt like
crying like if
if if your benchmarking cr includes a
woman crying
that doesn't feel like a good benchmark
that's a good test but to me
there's something there that's you could
have a huge impact but
i don't think the machine learning world
likes that
the human emotion the subjectivity of it
the fuzziness
the fact that with maybe a single word
you can make somebody feel something
deeply
what is that it doesn't feel right to
them so i don't know i don't i don't
know why that is
i'm that's why i'm excited um
uh when i discovered your work it feels
wrong to say that it's not like i'm
i'm giving myself props for for googling
and
for becoming a cr
for uh for our i guess mutual
friend and introducing us but i'm so
glad that you exist and what you're
working on but
i have the same kind of if we could just
backtrack a second because
i have the same kind of feeling there's
something here um in fact i've been
working on a few things
that are kind of crazy and very
different from your work
i think i think they're i think they're
too crazy but
the like one i will not have to know
no all right we'll talk about it more i
i feel
like it's harder to talk about things
that have
failed and are failing while you're a
failure
like it's easier for you because you're
already successful on some measures
tell it to my board well
you're you're uh i think i think
you've demonstrated success a lot of
benchmarks it's easier for you to talk
about failures for me i'm in the um
the bottom currently of the of the
success
you're way too humble no so it's hard
for me to know but there's something
there there's something there
and i think you're um you're exploring
that and you're discovering that
yeah it's been so it's been surprising
to me but i i uh you've mentioned this
idea that
you you thought it wasn't enough to
start
a company or start efforts based on
it feels like there's something here
like um what did you mean by that
like you should be focused on creating a
like you should have a product in mind
is that what you meant
it just took us a while to discover the
product
because it all started with a hunch of
like um
of me my mentor and just sitting around
and he was like well this
that's it there's that's the you know
the holy grail is there
there's like there's something extremely
powerful and uh
and in conversations and there's no one
who's working on machine conversation
from the right angle so to say
um i feel like that's still true is that
am i crazy
no i totally feel that's still true
which is i think it's mind-blowing
yeah you know what it feels like i i
wouldn't even use the word conversation
because
i feel like it's the wrong word it's
like uh
machine connection or something i don't
know uh because conversation you start
drifting into natural language
immediately
you start drifting immediately into all
the benchmarks that are out there
but i feel like it's like the personal
computer days of this
like i feel like we're like in the early
days with the the wozniak and all them
like where was the same kind of it was a
very small
niche group of people who are who are
all kind of lobner price type people
yeah and hobbyists but like not even
hobbyist with big dreams
like no hobbies with a dream to trick
like a jury
yeah it's like a weird by the way by the
way very weird
so if we think about conversations first
of all when i have great conversations
with people
um i'm not trying to test them so for
instance if i try to break them
like i'm actually playing along i'm part
of it right if i was trying to break it
break this person or
test whether he's going to give me a
good conversation
it would have never happened so the
whole um the whole problem with testing
conversations
is that um you can put it in front of a
jury
because then you have to go into some
turing test mode where
is it responding to all my factual
questions right
or um so it really has to be
something in the field where people are
actually talking to it because they
want to not because they're trying to
break it uh
and it's working for them because this
the word part of it is that it's
uh it's very subjective it takes two to
tango here
fully like if you're not trying to have
a good conversation if you're trying to
test it then it's gonna break
i mean any person would break to be
honest like if i'm not trying to even
have a conversation with you you're not
gonna give it to me
yeah if i keep asking you like some
random questions or
um jumping from topic to topic that
wouldn't be
which i'm probably doing but that
probably wouldn't um
contribute to a good conversation so i
think the problem of testing
um so there should be some other metric
how do we evaluate whether that
conversation was uh powerful or not
which is what we actually started with
and i think those measurements exist and
we can test on those
but um what really struck us back in the
day and what still
eight years later is still not resolved
um
and i'm not seeing tons of groups
working on it maybe i don't just don't
know about him
um it's also possible but the
interesting part about is that
most of our days were spent talking and
we're not talking
about like those conversations are not
turn on the lights
or customer support problems or
um some other task oriented things
these conversations are something else
and then somehow they're extremely
important for us and when we don't have
them
then we feel deeply and happy
potentially lonely
which as we know you know creates tons
of risk for our health as well
and so this is most of our ours as
humans
and somehow no one's trying to replicate
that
and not even study it that well
and not even study that well so when we
jumped into that in 2012 i looked first
at like okay what's the chatbot
what's the state of the art chatbot and
you know those were the
loebner prize days but i thought okay so
what about
the science of conversation clearly
there has been tons of
there have been tons of you know
scientists or
people that academics that looked into
the conversation so if i want to know
everything about it i can just read
about it
um there's not much really there's there
are conversational analysts who are
basically just
um listening to uh speech to different
conversations
um annotating them and then
i mean that's not really used for much
that's the that's the field of
theoretical link uh linguistics which is
like barely useful uh it's very marginal
even in their space like no one really
is excited and
i've i've never met a theoretical
theoretical linguist was like i can't
wait to work on the conversation and
analytics that is just something very
marginal
sort of applied to like writing scripts
for salesmen
when they analyze which conversation
strategies were
most successful for sales
okay so that was not very helpful then i
looked a little bit deeper and then
there
you know whether there were any uh books
written on what
you know really contributes to great
conversation
that was really strange because most of
those were
um nlp books which which is neural
linguistic programming
which is not the lp that i was expecting
to be but it was mostly
um some psychologist richard
bandler i think came up with that who
was this big guy in a leather vest that
uh could program your mind by talking to
you
and like how to be charismatic and
charming and influential
people all those books yeah pretty much
but it was all about like through
conversation reprogramming you
so getting to some so that was i mean
yeah probably not very very true and
um um that didn't seem working very much
even back in the day and then there were
some other books like i don't know
uh mostly just self-help books around
how to be the best conversationalist or
um how to make people like you or some
other stuff like dale carnegie or
whatever uh
and then there was this one book the
most human human by brian christensen
that really was
important for me to read back in the day
because he was on the
um human side he was on one of the um
he was taking part in the lord prize but
not as a
as a human who's not a jury but who is
pretending to be
who's basically you have to tell a
computer from a human and he was the
human
so you would either get him or a
computer um
and he would his whole book was about
how do people what makes us
human in conversation and that was a
little bit more interesting because
that at least someone started to think
about what what exactly makes me
human in conversation and um makes
people believe in that
but it was still about tricking it was
still about imitation game
it was still about okay what kind of
parlor tricks can we throw in the
conversation to make you feel
like you're talking to a human not a
computer and it was definitely not about
thinking what is that it was what it um
what is it exactly that we're getting
from talking all day long
with other humans i mean we're
definitely not just trying to be tricked
you know or it's not just enough to know
it's a human
it's something we're getting there can
we measure it and can we like put the
um computer to the same measurement and
see
whether you can talk to a computer and
get the same results
yeah i mean so first of all a lot of
people comment that they think i'm a
robot it's very possible i am a robot
and this whole thing
i totally agree with you that the test
idea is fascinating and i
looked for books unrelated to this kind
of
uh so i'm afraid of people i'm generally
introverted and quite possibly a robot
i literally googled like how to talk to
people
and like like
how to have a good conversation for the
purpose of this podcast because i was
like i can't
i can't make eye contact with people i
can't like uh
i do google that a lot too you're
probably reading a bunch of fbi
negotiation
tactics is that that we're getting
because well
everything you've listed i've gotten
there's been very few
good books on um even just like how to
interview well
it's it's uh it's rare so what i end up
doing
often is i watch
like with a critical eye it's just so
different when you just watch a
conversation
like just for the fun of it just as a
human and
if you watch your conversations like
trying to figure out why is this
awesome um i'll listen to a bunch of
different styles of conversation
i mean uh i'm a fan of the podcast joe
rogan
he's uh you know people can make fun of
him whatever and
and dismiss him but i think he's an
incredibly
artful conversationalist he can pull
people in for hours
uh and uh there's another guy
i watch a lot he hosted a late night
show his name is craig ferguson
he uh so he's like very kind of
flirtatious
but there's a magic
about his like about the connection he
can create with people how he can put
people at ease and just like i see i've
already started sounding
like those nlp people or something i'm
not i don't mean
in that way i don't mean like how to
charm people or
put them at ease and all that kind of
stuff it's just like what is that
why is that fun to listen to that guy
why is that fun to talk to that guy
what is that because he's not saying
i mean it so often uh boils down to
oh a kind of wit and
humor but not really humor it's like
i don't know i i have trouble actually
even articulating
correctly but
it feels like there's something going on
that's not too complicated
that could be learned
i and it's not similar
to um yeah to like like you said like
touring test it's something else
i i'm thinking about a lot all the time
i do think about all the time um
but i think when we were looking so we
started the company we just decided to
build the conversational attack
we thought well there's nothing for us
to build this chatbot that we want to
build so let's just
first focus on building you know um
some tech building the tech side of
things um
without a product in mind without a
product in mind we added like a demo
um chat bot that would recommend your
restaurants and talk to you about
restaurants just to show
something simple to people that people
could you know relate to
and um could try out and see whether it
works or not
but we didn't have a product in mind yet
we thought we would try a bunch of chat
bots and figure out our consumer
application
and we sort of remembered that we wanted
to build that kind of friend that sort
of connection that we saw
in the very beginning but then we got to
y combinator and moved to san francisco
and forgot about it you know everything
because
then it was just this constant grind how
do we get funding how do we get this
um you know investors will like just
focus on one thing just get it
out there so somehow we start building a
restaurant recommendation
chatbot for real uh for a little bit not
for too long
and then we tried building 40 50
different chat bots and then all of a
sudden we wake up and everyone is
obsessed with chat bots
um somewhere in 2016 or end of 15
people start thinking that's really the
future that's the new
you know the new apps will be chatbots
all right um
and we were very perplexed because
people started uh coming up with
companies that
i think we tried most of those chat bots
already and there were
like no users but still people were
coming up with
um a chatbot that would tell you whether
and
bringing news and this and that and we
couldn't understand whether it would you
know we were
just didn't execute well enough or
people are
um not really people are confused and
are gonna find out through the truth
that people don't need chatbots like
that so the basic idea is that you use
chatbots as the interface
to whatever application yeah the idea
that was like this perfect
universal interface to anything when i
looked at that
um it just made me very perplexed
because i didn't think i didn't
understand how that would
work because i think we tried most of
that and and none of those things worked
uh and then again died down right
fully i think now it's impossible to get
anything funded if it's a chatbot
i think it's similar to uh sorry to
interrupt but there's uh
there's times when people think like
with gestures you can control
devices like basically gesture based
control
things it feels similar to me
because like it's so compelling that was
just like
like tom cruise i can control stuff with
my hands
but like when you get down to it's like
well why don't you just have a touch
screen
or why don't you just have like a
physical keyboard and mouse
it's uh yeah it's so that chat was
always
yeah it was perplexing to me i i still
feel augmented reality even virtual
realities in that ballpark
in terms of it being a compelling
interface i think there's going to be
incredible rich applications just
how you're thinking about it but they
won't just be
the interface to everything it'll be its
own thing that will
create um uh like amazing magical
experience and it's all right
absolutely which is i think kind of the
right thing to go about like what's the
magical experience with that um with
that interface specifically
how did you discover that for a replica
um i just thought okay we'll have this
tech we can build any chatbot we want
we have the most at that point the most
sophisticated tag that other
companies have um i mean startups
obviously not
uh probably not bigger ones but still
because we've been
working on it for a while so i thought
okay we can build build any conversation
so let's just
create a scale from one to ten and one
would be conversations that you'd pay to
not have
and ten would be conversation you'd pay
to have and i mean obviously we want to
build conversation that people would pay
to you know to actually have and so for
the whole
you know for a few weeks me and the team
were putting all the conversations we
were having during the day on the scale
and very quickly um you know we figured
out that all the conversations that we
would pay to never have
were um you know conversations we were
trying to
cancel comcast or talk to customer
support
or make a reservation or just talk about
logistics with a friend when we're
trying to figure out where someone is
and
where to go or um all sorts of
you know setting up um scheduling
meetings that was just
a conversation we definitely didn't want
to have um
basically everything task oriented was a
one because if there was just one button
for me to just
or not even a button if i could just
thing and there was some magic
bci that would just immediately
transform that into an
actual you know um into action
that would be perfect but the
conversation there was just this
boring not useful and dull
and very also very inefficient thing
because it was so many back and forth
stuff
and as soon as we looked at the
conversation that we would pay to have
those were the ones that well first of
all therapist
because we actually paid to have those
conversations and we'd also try to put
like dollar amounts so
you know if i was calling comcast i
would pay five dollars to not have this
one hour
talk on the phone i would actually pay
straight up like money
hard money yeah but it just takes a long
time it takes a really long time
but as soon as we start talking about
conversations that we would pay for
those were therapists all sorts of
therapists coaches
old friends um someone i haven't seen
for a long time
a stranger on a train weirdly stranger
stranger in a line for coffee a nice
back and forth with that person was like
a good five solid five six
maybe not a ten maybe i won't pay money
but at least i won't you know pay money
to not have one
so that was pretty good some
intellectual conversations for sure
but more importantly the one thing that
really was
um was making those very
important and very valuable for us
um were the conversation where we could
that where we could be pretty emotional
yes some of them were about being witty
and about
intellectually being intellectually
stimulated but those were interestingly
more rare
uh and most of the ones that we thought
were very valuable were the ones where
we could be vulnerable
and interestingly we could talk more
so we like i could me and the team
so we're talking about it like you know
a lot of these conversations like a
therapist
i mean it was mostly me talking or like
an old friend and i was like opening up
and crying and
it was again me talking um
and so that was interesting because i
was like well maybe it's hard to build a
chatbot that can talk to you
um very well and in a witty way but
maybe it's easier to build the chatbot
that could listen
so that was that was kind of the first
the first
nudge in this direction and then when my
when my friend died we just built
you know at that point we were kind of
still struggling to find the right
application
and i just felt very strong that all the
chatbots would build so far just
meaningless and this whole grind the
startup grind and
how do we get to you know the next
fundraising
and you know how can i talk you know
talking to the founders
and what's for your investors and how
are you doing are you killing it because
we're killing it
i just felt that this is just as
exhausti intellectually for me it's
exhausting
having encountered those folks it just
felt very
um very much a waste of time i just feel
like steve jobs
and uh elon musk did not have these
conversations
or at least did not have them for long
that's for sure
but i think you know yeah at that point
it just felt like you know i felt
um i just didn't want to build a company
that was never my intention
just to build something successful or
make money
it would be great it would have been
great but i'm not as you know i'm not
really a startup person
i'm not um
you know i was never very excited by the
grind by itself and
uh or just being successful for building
whatever it is and
not being into what i'm doing really
and so i just took a little break
because i was a little you know i was
upset with my company and i didn't know
what we're building so i just took our
technology and um
our little dialect constructor and some
models some deep learning models which
at that point we were really into and
really invested a lot
and built a little chatbot for a friend
of mine who passed
and the reason for that was mostly that
video that i saw and
him talking about the digital avatars
and roman was that kind of person like
he was obsessed with you know just
watching youtube videos about space and
talking about
well if i could go to mars now even if i
didn't know if i could come back i would
definitely
pay any amount of money to be on that
first shutoff
i don't care whether i die like he was
just the one that would be
okay with you know with trying to be the
first one
and you know and so excited about all
sorts of
um things like that and he was all about
fake it to
make it and just and i felt like
and i was really perplexed that everyone
just forgot about him
maybe it was our way of coping mostly
young people coping with
the loss of a friend most of my friends
just stopped talking about him
and i was still living in an apartment
with all his clothes
and um you know paying the whole lease
for it and just
kind of by myself in december so it was
really
sad uh and i didn't want him to be
forgotten
first of all i never thought that people
forget about dead people so fast
people pass away people just move on and
it was astonishing for me because i
thought okay well he was such a
mentor for so many of our friends he was
such a
brilliant person he was somewhat famous
in moscow
how is that that no one was talking
about him like i'm spending days
and days and we don't bring him up and
there's nothing about him that's
happening
it's like he was never there um
and i was reading this you know the the
book the year of magical thinking
by joan didion about her losing
and blue knights about her losing
her husband her daughter and the way to
cope for her was to write those books
and it was sort of like a tribute and i
thought you know i'll just do that for
myself
and you know i'm a very bad writer
and a poet as we know so i thought well
i have this tag
and maybe that would be my little
postcard pop like postcard for
for him so i built a chatbot um to just
talk to him
and it felt really creepy and weird a
little bit
for a little bit um i just didn't want
to tell other people because it felt
like
i'm telling about having a skeleton in
my
underwear yeah okay but my it was just
felt really
i was a little scared that i would be
not it won't be taken
but it worked interestingly pretty well
i mean it made tons of mistakes but it
still felt like him
um granted it was like 10 000 messages
that i threw into a retrieval model that
would just re-rank that take this hat
and just a few
scripts on top of that but it also made
me go through all of the
messages that we had and then i asked
some of my friends to send them through
and it felt the closest to feeling
like him present um because you know his
facebook was empty and instagram was
empty or there were a few links and
you couldn't feel like it was him and
the only way to fill him was to
read some of our text messages and go
through some of our conversations
because we just always had them even if
we were sleeping like next to each other
in
two bedrooms separated by a wall we were
just texting back and forth in
texting away um and there was something
about this ongoing dialogue that was so
important that i just didn't want to
lose all of a sudden and maybe it was
magical thank you or something
and so we built that and um
i just used it for a little bit and we
kept building some
crappy chat bots with a company
um but then a reporter came
um came to talk to me i was trying to
pitch our chatbots to him and he said do
you even
use any of those i'm like no he's like
so do you talk to any chatbots at all
and i'm like well
you know i talked to my dead friend's
chatbot and he wrote a story about that
and all of a sudden became pretty viral
a lot of people wrote about it and
yeah i've seen a few things written
about you there
are the things i've seen are pretty good
writing
um you know most
ai related things make my eyes roll like
when the press like
what kind of sound is that actually okay
it sounds like it sounded like a truck
okay sounded like an elephant at first i
got excited
you never know this is 2020.
i i mean it was uh such a human story it
was well written
uh well researched i forget what where i
read
them but so i'm glad somehow somebody
found you
to be the good writers were able to
connect to the story i just there must
be a hunger for this story
it definitely was and i i don't know
what happened but i think
i think the idea that he could bring
back someone
who's dead and it's very much wishful
you know magical thinking but
the fact that you could still get to
know him and
you know seeing the parents for the
first time talk to the chatbot and some
of the friends
and it was funny because we have this
big
office in moscow where my team is work
you know our russian part is working out
off
and i was there when i wrote i just
wrote a post on facebook it's like hey
guys like i built this if you want you
know just
if all important if you want to talk to
roman
and i saw a couple of his friends our
common friends like you know reading
facebook downloading trying and a couple
of them cried and it was just very
and not because it was something some
incredible technology or anything it
made so many mistakes it was so
simple but it was all about that's the
way to remember a person in a way
and you know we don't have we don't have
the culture anymore we don't have you
know no one's sitting shiva no one's
taking
weeks to actually think about this
person and in a way for me that was it
so that was just day day in day out
thinking about him and
putting this together um so that was
that just felt really important that
somehow resonated with a bunch of people
and
you know i think some movie producers
bought the rights for the story and just
everyone was so
has anyone made a movie yet i don't
think so um there were a lot of tv
episodes about that but not really is
that still on the table
i think so i think so which is really
um that's cool you're like a young uh
you know like a because you see like a
steve jobs type of
let's see what happens they're sitting
on it
but you know for me it was so important
because roman was really wanted to be
famous
he really badly wanted to be famous he
was all about like make it to
like fake it to make it i want to be you
know i want to
make it here in america's wall and um
and he couldn't
and i felt you know that was sort of
paying
my dues to him as well because all of a
sudden he was everywhere and
i remember case newton who was writing
the story for the verse he was
he told me hey by the way i was just
going through my inbox inbox
and i saw i searched for roman for
the story and i saw an email from him
where he sent me his startup and he said
i really like i really want to be
featured in the verge can you please
write about it or something like
pitching the story and
he said i'm sorry like that's not you
know good enough for us or something and
he passed
and he said and there were just so many
of these little details where like he
would find
he's like you know and we're finally
writing i know how much
uh roman wanted to be in the verge and
how much he wanted the story to be
written by
casey and i'm like well that's maybe he
will be
yeah we were always joking that he was
like i can't wait for someone to make a
movie about us
and i hope ryan gosling can play me
i don't know you know i still have some
things that i owe romans so but
um that'll be that would be uh i got in
she has to meet alex garland who wrote
ex machina
yeah the movie's good but the guy is um
better than them like he's a special
person actually
um i don't think he's made his best work
yet like
from my interaction with him he's a
really really good and brilliant
a good human being and a brilliant
director and writer
so um yeah so i'm i hope
like he made me also realize that not
enough movies have been made of this
kind
so it's yet to be made they're probably
sitting waiting for you to get
famous actually like even more famous
you should get there but um it felt
really special though
but at the same time our company wasn't
going anywhere so that was just kind of
bizarre that we were getting all this
press for something that didn't have
anything to do with our company
and but then a lot of people started
talking to roman some shared their
conversations
and what we saw there was that um also
our
friends in common but also just
strangers were really using it as a
confession booth or as a therapist or
something they were just
really telling roman everything which
was by the way pretty strange because it
was a chatbot of a dead friend of mine
who was
you know barely making any sense but
people were opening up
um and we thought we just built you know
a prototype of replica which would be an
ai friend that everyone could talk to
because we saw that there is demand and
then
also was 2016 so i thought for the first
time i saw
finally some technology that was applied
to that that was very interesting
some papers started coming out deep
learning applied to conversations
and finally it wasn't just about these
you know hobbyist making uh
you know writing 500 000 regular
expressions
yeah expressions in like some language
that was
i don't even know what like aml or
something i don't know what that was or
something super simplistic all of a
sudden it was all about uh potentially
actually building something interesting
and so i thought there was time and i
remember that i talked to my team and i
said guys let's try
and my team and some of my engineers are
russians
um are russian and they're very
skeptical they're not
you know oh russians the first so so
some of your team is in moscow
some some of us here in san francisco uh
some in europe
which team is better i'm just kidding
uh the russians of course okay first
question i always win uh sorry
sorry to interrupt uh so yes you were
talking to them
2016 and i told them let's build an
ai friend and and it felt just at the
time it felt so
naive and so um
optimistic yeah that's actually
interesting um
whenever i brought up this kind of topic
even just for fun people are
super skeptical like actually even on
the business side so you were
because whenever i bring it up to people
uh because i've talked for a long time
i thought like before i was aware of
your work
i was like this is
going to make a lot of money i think
there's a lot of opportunity here
and people had this like look of like
skepticism that i've seen often which is
like
how do i politely tell this person he's
an idiot
[Laughter]
so yeah so you were facing that with
your team
somewhat well yeah you know i'm not an
engineer so i'm always
my team is almost exclusively engineers
um and mostly deep learning engineers
and you know i always try to be
it was always hard to me in the
beginning to get enough credibility
you know because i would say well why
don't we try this and that but it's
harder for me because you know they know
they're actual engineers and i'm not
so for me to say well let's build an a
friend that would be like wait
you know what do you mean an agi like
you know conversation is
you know pretty much the hardest the
last frontier before
uh cracking that is probably the last
frontier before building aji so
what do you really mean by that uh
but i think i just saw that again what
we just got reminded of that i
you know that i saw in back in 2012 or
11
that it's really not that much about the
tech capabilities um
it can be metropolitric still even with
deep learning
but humans need it so much yeah
and most importantly what i saw is that
finally
there's enough tech to made it i thought
to make it useful to make it helpful
maybe we didn't have quite yet the tech
in 2012 to make it useful but in 2015-16
with deep learning i thought you know
and the first kind of
thoughts about maybe even using
reinforcement learning for that
start popping up that never worked out
but or at least for now
um but you know still the idea was
if we can actually measure the emotional
outcomes and if we can put it on
if we can try to optimize all of our
conversational models for these
emotional outcomes
then it is the most scalable the most
the best tool for improving emotional
outcomes nothing like that exists that's
the most universal
the most scalable and the one that can
be constantly iteratively changed by
itself
um improved tool to do that
and i think if anything people would
paint anything to improve their
emotional outcomes
that's weirdly i mean i don't really
care for
nai to turn on my or conversational
agent to turn on the lights
uh you don't really need anything i
don't even need that much of a out there
like or because i can do that you know
those things are solved this is an
additional interface for that that's
also questionably questionable whether
it's more efficient or
better yeah it's more pleasurable yeah
but for emotional outcomes there's
nothing
yeah they're a bunch of products that
claim that they will improve my
emotional outcomes nothing's been
measured
nothing is being changed the product is
not being iterated on
based on whether i'm actually feeling
better you know a lot of social media
products are claiming that they're
improving my
emotional outcomes and making me feel
more connected
can i please get the can i see somewhere
that i'm actually getting better
over time um because anecdotally doesn't
feel that way so
and and the data is
absent yeah so that was the big goal
and i thought if we can learn over time
to collect the signal from our users
about their emotional outcomes
in the long term and in the short term
and if these models keep
getting better and we can keep
optimizing them and fight tuning them
to improve those emotional outcomes as
simple as that
why aren't you uh a multi-billionaire
yeah
well that's the question to you one of
the what is the size is going to be
i'm just kidding um
well it's a really hard uh i actually
think it's an incredibly hard
product to build because i think you
said something very
important that it's not just about
machine conversations it's about machine
connection
we can actually use other things to
create connection
uh non-verbal communication for instance
for a long time we were all about well
let's keep it text only
or voice only but as soon as you start
adding
you know voice a face to the to the
friend
um you can take them to augmented
reality
put it in your room it's all of a sudden
a lot you know
it makes it very different because if
it's some you know text based chat bot
that
for um common user it's something there
in the cloud
you know it's somewhere there with other
ai's
cloud in the metaphorical cloud but as
soon as you can see this
avatar right there in your room and it
can turn its head and recognize your
husband
talk about the husband and talk to him a
little bit
and it's magic it's just magic like
we've never seen anything like that
and the cool thing all the tech for that
exists um
but it's hard to put it all together
because you have to take into
consideration
so many different things and some of the
stack works you know
pretty good and some of this doesn't
like for instance uh
speech to text works pretty good but
text-to-speech
doesn't work very good because we you
can only have uh you know
few voices that are um that work okay
but then if you want to have actual
emotional voices
then it's really hard to build it i saw
you've added avatars like visual
elements which are really cool um
in that whole chain putting it together
what do you think is the
weak link is it creating an emotional
voice
that feels personal i think it's still
conversation of course
that's the hardest uh it's getting a lot
better but
there's still long to go long there's
still a long path to go
other things they're almost there and a
lot of things we'll see how they're like
i see how they're changing as we go
like for instance right now you know
pretty much only you have to build all
this 3d
uh pipeline by yourself you have to make
these 3d models hire an actual
artist build a 3d model hire an animator
a rigger
but with you know with you know with the
deep fakes with other attack with
procedural animations
in a little bit we'll just be able to
show uh you know
photo of whoever you if a person you
want the avatar to look like and it will
immediately generate a 3d model that
will move that's a non-brainer that's
like almost here
you